hey guys this is dennis to founder thick
here and i'm david griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of agents of shield
episode 5 the girl in the flower dress
ok so the thing is this is episode 5
right yeah the last several episodes
have felt like they're the same thing
yeah like the same stuff happens they
pick like a sum like you know entity or
God and like has some sort of power or
something and then they have to come in
and swoop in to save the day or get some
information it just it seems like we're
watching the same thing week to week
yeah but I mean this week we get to see
sky in our underwear that should be
enough that should just be like oh my
gosh I mean now see ya it's I don't know
I I don't want to bash the shell because
I know it's early and I know it's it's
got a key to the person who wrote this
show Brent Fletcher a veteran wrote like
a bunch of episodes on Spartacus where
the damn josh wink I wrote some angel
loss to me this guy's been around like I
was like oh this guy's ride this episode
this could be good maybe some or carry
development they tried to we got to give
him some credit they did try to build
skies character up a little bit I don't
think it was a great attempt but they
tried I had to give him credit on that
they did try i think the problem i have
you know i've been talking about this oh
I don't believe sky is a hacker stuff
and this isn't like sexist or anything
cuz I don't buy that other guy miles is
a hacker either right the dude that she
sleeps with in the episode I'm like well
I don't buy him as a hacker either and
then at the end when he's like doing
this on the table with the graphical
interface that's his like version of
hacking yeah like no man and why do we
always have to have these all this
hacker hacking stuff in all these agents
of shield episodes because it's not
agents of hacking no I mean I don't I
just don't I don't know what the show
was trying to do the problems about
every time I watch I'm like what are you
trying to get from me here we're not
getting the character development I feel
like everybody was saying like oh they
had this big store that we get a little
Gravitron or whatever a few episodes of
back with him reaching through the field
we get at the end of each episode is
always some little cliffhanger wasn't
some that's building but I'm like okay
you can build a world I'm fine with that
but give me some characters that I want
to care about I don't care what I said
last week I still don't care
even with this backstory with Scott I
care about Coulson I care about a
Melinda may mean Owens character like
those two are the ones that I am most
invested in but yeah the rest of them I
don't really care that much forward and
they did try to make sky a more
sympathetic enjoy earlier with the the
reveal that the reason why she's trying
to infiltrate shield is that she wants
to find out what happened with her
parents cuz something happened with her
parents with shield and yeah I mean I
guess that's supposed to draw us into
her but it really doesn't for me I feel
like cuz this show is a big show it's
it's Marvel agents of shield you know so
it's got this huge university' to go
from but I feel like it has to start the
most essential things to start with
character building I think you know I
mentioned shows like Spartacus started
small small characters built up to war
of the damned supernatural starts them
all learn about the two brothers builds
up to Lucifer vs angels I think all this
stuff like you have to give us the
characters and then you can like build
up and get this story going but I feel
like they're just trying to go straight
for the story without giving us any of
the care of their episodic stories
they're like every shows with
self-contained thing there are little
elements of hinting at a bigger story
you know you have this girl in the
flower address she must play a big yeah
role in this in the future of the show
because they called the episode that and
at the end she goes and sees that guy in
prison ask them to see the clairvoyant
and so so they do give us these little
in something better and bigger but
between right yeah there are some of its
with everybody and when you you and I
say something against it show some
people respond like we'll just wait I'm
like okay but give me something in
between the waiting that I can hold on
to I'm fine with waiting for a big thing
at the end but like give me something to
hold on so I looked like they'd give me
an you know they had this character of
yen who's who's this Chinese like a
magician street performer yeah they went
bad fast yeah bad i mean is you know he
wants to be scorched well and and so
they have him but he seems disposable to
me I think that's the thing is like you
have all these villains or or enemies by
the phone is the pilot even I liked him
just kind of get rid of them yeah so
just kind of disposable and and maybe I
don't know at the end this season
they're gonna bring all these characters
back or so yeah maybe yeah maybe then
they'll be cool they'll be like oh yeah
they set that up before but right now it
just seems like they just using these
these these characters just for one-off
see let's get them in this episode get
them out you know yeah i mean i don't
know it's everything just I can't tell
what that when I can't tell if they want
to be campy but they want to be serious
or when they're seriously want to be
can't be like with the two gorgeous
female doctors you know like in the
surgery room they have the one who
flower dress you have the the main
doctor who's like oh my god she's dead
now it's like well why like what's her
history i was surprised though when they
killed that one doctor by the plaintiff
rider that was robbed I've seen no but I
was like cuz most this shows me pretty
family-friendly sure that was a bit grew
so that was good yeah like to think
about that he got burnt alive right
Chris I was surprised by that yeah it
was rough i mean i don't know i mean i-i
me are you still like are you like I
mean are you giving those are both give
chance i said on to her last night I
will watch I'm not gonna watch the
entire scene I'll get the first season I
promise I will do that but I mean you
excited when you start watching this on
what do you know I mean hopeful hopeful
right now because they're now giving me
anything to look forward you know I just
feel like every episode okay it's just
gonna be this thing and then after it's
done i'm not gonna think about it every
right again you know it's not like oh my
god this you know did you see last
night's ages are you that you know this
and this happened you know that's what
good television does yes like you're
like oh my god this happened and you
talk with your friends about it right
hey like we gotta you know like what do
you think about this and this and then
right now it's like there's none of that
yeah this speculation is very minimal I
think like I said I don't want to sound
like I'm bachelor I don't think it's an
awful show well it's not a [ __ ] is so
average yes I think it's very average in
there its original yeah but not bad as
potential has the cast to do what it
needs to do but need to give the lead
the the guy the agent the Navy's what's
that I was forget advise me I'm sorry
grant grant I gotta give grants
something to do like him but I see
to the lead though he feels like sky is
the lead you know and like you know she
goes off and betrays shield and sleeps
with that guy and I was like how she's
still part of shield that's what I
understand at the end Lyta how she's
still part of this should she like be
like in jail all right thing in
fitzsimmons and do hardly anything this
episode I still don't besides her
British banter i'm not sure what they're
there for so i don't know i just need to
say i hope they give us a little more
character development it's all I'm
asking for yeah I want some more
character development I want a larger
story I want something that I want
something to look forward to and this
easier this would get picked up for full
runs maybe a second half of the season
we could see some fruit maybe we got
thor coming out in a couple weeks so
maybe little I don't know they got that
dimension Thor and it had to be like hey
some big attack in London some elf guy
attacks even they have to mention
something I I hope so yeah it is it is
having a full season but I no ratings
are slipping they are continually going
on yeah especially like for a show
that's Ariane episode 5 they said that
usually by now most shows have
stabilized to what their ratings are
going to break and shield is still
falling week to week so there's still
people just that are curious that are
checking it out rather like trying to
hold on but they can go shoulder
conversation starters I mean I want to
we were past the time of the watercourse
isn't the 90s anymore but but it's
twitter twitter facebook people get
excited when game of thrones' on youtube
people got excited about oranges and new
black even though wasn't like per
episode was like if you were like hey if
you check out the show on netflix you
gotta watch all of them with a black
totally was like glue up yeah like
everyone's like oh you've got to see it
you got to see it with Marvel it's
really tough you looks like yeah I'm
checking it out I'm watching it but no
one's like no one goes in about no one's
buzz no buzz yeah yeah so yeah so I
don't know what do you guys think of
this episode what do you think of you
know what the rest of the season holds
you can post your comments on the
website thing CARICOM or our youtube
channel think hero pro make sure you
subscribe to that come talk to us on
twitter too and talk to Dennis and I
everybody here with that at think hero
personally i'm at griffin de and we
asked on the facebook page that's a
facebook.com slash think hero fans
you